what's up everyone welcome back we are
at women in tech international we are
now sitting down with Rhonda Childress
thank you for having me thanks for
coming on the show appreciate it greatly
appreciate it Congrats on your award
thank you very much and great talk today
lunch oh thank you I really look talking
about women and security and the
diversity that's necessary to be brought
to that that field so yes let's on let's
unpack that so you are a IBM fellow of
VP data data security and privacy
officer right yes and that has how long
has that been going on
I actually just since the beginning of
this year okay so the VP title since the
beginning this year the I've info for I
think three or four years okay and you
have like a hundred and fifty six or
something patents that have been filed
now actually granted grant I mean sorry
granted you have like over two hundred
or something fine
yeah about it yeah something like that
yeah so granted patents I mean and this
is like you run around the world and
you're looking around you see things
that can be better and you're like I'm
gonna patent that you can't you can't I
often I carry a pad of paper pencil with
me and I hear people say I wish I had
yeah I wish I had and you sort of drop
the idea down and then you you sort of
create this book of ideas in and we have
patent groups to get together and we
look at these kinds of things and say
what can we do and you know how can we
fix some of these things that we see
like to me the best one was some of the
things that they did when I got sick so
my team I had four pulmonary embolisms
chewing each lung was really severe
blood clots blood clot so I had two big
blood clots in both lungs so my
breathing was it was like having an
asthma attack and it was treated a
couple times like I was having an asthma
attack I had a very bright doctor who
recognized it did the necessary blood
work found out I had blood clots sent me
to the hospital
Wow and so I was in ICU they gave me
cheap ei which is what they give stroke
victims because it was so bad what is
TPA it's I wish I knew it was but it is
a drug they give stroke victims right
away so it's that
that you're supposed to get within a
certain period of time for it to make a
difference I know it's very expensive I
got the bill bill it's very expensive
but in it I did have to sign some
paperwork for experimental use of its a
non-traditional treatment for it to try
to break those clots up and so I was in
the hospital and you would get your
blood drawn three times a day and you
would get coumadin shots in your stomach
it was not fun and I had a very bright
nurse who said look if we can figure out
how to keep you moving and you need to
take medication every day you know
within certain parameters you know we
can get you out here I was like I am so
in for this because you know every time
every day you're there the clocks
running and so I called my guys and said
guys look here's what has to happen and
and we went to work right away so we in
created an IOT pill bottle the ones that
they had on the market at the time were
either had an alarm on top I did try to
put the alarm on my phone and say take
my medicine but I would get busy and
you're on a phone call the alarm goes
off you just off it and you go oh crap
did I take it did I not take it oh
interesting so the idea was to put the
alarm on the bottle so they put them on
the car and I'm like okay so even if
you're in the middle of the call you
enlighten us
that's one of the ones they had and then
another one they had though had to be
programmed by the pharmacist so I said
you know can't we take some of these IOT
devices we had we had a $26 Broadcom
wicked cents we smashed it open and took
the parts out david chimere's who's a
friend he created a sleeve a plastic
sleeve we put this at the bottom and the
premise was is if I push down and turn
the cap take the childproof cap off
followed by a tilting action tilting
that go out in my hand pretty darn good
you know reason that I'm going to take
that medication yeah so it's there just
an alarm or it haven't you had the
pharmacist I've got a sleeve which by
the way can be used for universal you
know pill bottles only come like four
different sleeves sizes so you can do
this and then Mike Spisak the
interstates that we push down you do
this you tilt it it's in your hand you
take
the medication and it registers with the
IOT it registers that you did these
motions and you're not selling massive
they're reusable they're reusable exact
not reinventing the pill bottle you're
only adding it is cheap cheap like ten
bucks
very cheap because you know I'm sure we
could have gotten the IOT WIC Broadcom
wicked sense sensors but you just need
one that's got that clicky push button
and the the you know gyroscope that
tells you whether you're tilting or not
and oh you need to know that yeah this
is more expensive 10 bucks n-no no no
actually you know Broadcom wicked sense
the $26 sensor it's it's all there and
you could probably if you buy stuff and
that's not buying it in there yeah yeah
you know you could probably get the
sensors very cheaply now but there's a
gyroscope because you need to know when
they actually you tell - because
otherwise the alarm goes off and well
then tomorrow it doesn't alarm so you're
supposed to take this so there's no
alarm on this one you just push down so
it does you know alarm on this bed yeah
so you push down right so it it clicks
take the top off and then you tilt the
action got chills in your hands without
is 98 percent right ninety bottle all
right ninety-eight percent chance you're
going to take the medication for you so
the old ones used to have the alarm on
it that's that was the one incorporation
that we found in the prior art and the
other one was just very complicated you
know it counts them you know the pill
rolls down this this track and it comes
out and stuff like that and there's
never a guarantee that you're gonna take
it kind of thing sounds great so it's
very simple it's very simple and then
the guys did this whole tracking
interface my left I said guys let's be
simple frowny face red happy face green
mutual face gray you know and so it's
all very it's all very simple and just
think about your being able to give this
to your parents correct you're not there
with your parents are your parents
taking their medications when they're
supposed to take their medications and
you can track them from afar and have
these things or you can even with me you
know we can't
you know I didn't do it so maybe my
husband caught you know it it says okay
she's now thirty minutes out for me she
should have taken it she's you know i
paged her you know you got an SMS on
your phone and she said I'm not doing it
let me call her then call the HOS you
know what does husband know she's not
taking it and the husband could take
corrective action you know that so that
was the pill bottle part and then the
movement part was the guys would go into
my calendar and rearrange my calendar so
every 15 minutes I moved I had to move I
had two hours and I had to move from
another 15 minutes so they would
rearrange my calendar to make sure I had
the time to do what is moving if I moved
early we arranged these kinds of things
but it would remind me to do what I
supposed to do yeah some of the
enhancements that that they're working
on it would say Ronnie you cannot do
this so that you could live you could be
healthy yes and I could have a hospital
but yeah so I should live and be healthy
and I'm really there's like literature
now that people's take better care of
when their animals need medication than
when they need medication we do and if
you actually look in the patent stuff
like we were talking before it there's a
ton of patents on pet care just a
boatload of patents on pet care and not
a lot of people care yeah but have a
snow machine if you think about it
there's like there's more dogs in San
Francisco than there are babies yes but
we do that in but my my um being on
college she's like when are you guys
gonna you know sell these things it's my
patients need these kinds of things and
these are the things that we look at you
know and it just grew out of a need for
me but it was I need a boom guys and I
were right on right on it you know so
that's such an interesting way of
thinking you know you're telling us a
bit about your background off-camera and
I think that having we talked about
necessity being the mother of invention
and having all these variables kind of
crunching at around you in your
environment that you feel forced to
maybe MacGyver something or when you see
things like what do we need to do for
kids especially young women especially
the see it be it mentality but like when
you see something and you
make it better you know the track to
make it better you have a mentor there
to help you make that into the world
right great great and that that's really
you know what I like to do is how can we
help these young ladies do this kind of
these kinds of things you know how can
how can they see something and then
realize it and make it better girls who
code oh I loved the summers with girls
who code I love those summers because
they always come up with the most
interesting projects and these kinds of
things that that they're doing for that
for the betterment and then I find out
that a lot of them continue on as a
group after the end of the summer of
girls our code to continue betterment of
those projects that they started and it
was it was really cool so the first
summer I was with IBM unfortunately I
got sent to China for the graduation
then I told the group I said I'm sorry
because I always tried to make time to
go be with them when at least once a
week and I said I won't be here what
they didn't realize was is I had made
arrangements that you know there's
rolling robots mm-hmm but they had I had
made arrangements to come in from China
that morning so it was morning in China
at night in the u.s. to attend the
graduation ceremony I was really afraid
that something was going to happen and
the Chinese were gonna block that you
know that capability so we had like plan
a plan B Plan C you know luckily
everything panned out and I was able to
roll in on the robot and you know look
at all their projects and interact with
them with the rolling robot that morning
the client was fantastically wonderful
about giving me those three hours to be
with the girls you know tell them what
we were doing and good and and they were
just so gracious to say yes please you
know take care of that and we'll you
know switch our morning to the afternoon
and we'll just do that but those are the
kinds of things that make it worthwhile
is being able to work with those want
those young ladies on these kinds of
things and it's like a inventor
mentality as well and instilling that
from the parents and the community and
the kid and just the fabric around you
social fabric is how can we actualize
people to actually come up with these
thoughts ask creative and critical
thinkers and be able to actually build
in problem solvers and problem solvers
and how do we enable them with the right
skill sets to do this you know or how
can you build a diverse group that has
the skill sets that you need to do this
it's like that purple skirt I don't know
that you saw that the the
the little video that they had they
could see got like that purple skirt you
know if it wasn't for Tim for she who
had the time and the knowledge to put
together the tweeny the booth right
chipsets with the ble with the
programming while I was handling the
creation of the skirt the design what we
needed it to do when all of that we
would have never had it and it grew out
of the necessity to on the first stem
broadcast where we had 300 in the honest
but we had a live stream audience at
that time with twenty thousand kids so
how do you engage twenty thousand kids
when you're talking to three hundred in
the audience Twitter or something yes so
you know how did we do this and when I
first said let's build a Twitter skirt
everywhere man was like we are not
following you thank you very much and I
would explain it and they still didn't
get it and luckily Tim was right there
with me and he I got it
you know and and so I built part of it
and I built the panel that had the LEDs
on it and did some of the soldering and
I sent it to Tim and Tim finished it
while I finish doing the other bits and
bobs that needed to be done then you
know boom the purple skirt was born and
you know was a big hit with the kids
yeah but it was just it wasn't that we
needed something but we did need
something it was like it wasn't like bad
habit but I wanted something that would
engage those kids so they could see
their art as possible so you know it's
just one of those things that you know
that my team is always going what is she
gonna come up with now that's a good
character to be in your groups around
you is what's this person going to do
next what are they going to come up with
next how are they going to innovate or
create how are they going to help young
kids that want to be actualized in the
world like that's a great role to have
in your commitment I would I would love
I work with the
the Scott family amazing do you know
them and Bentonville Arkansas the Scott
family may seem if you haven't been
there you have to go and it's a great
great area and I've worked with them and
hey you know they've offered me a
tinkerer and residents I'm like oh my
god that would be so I heard you're in
residence would that not be an awesome
job to have to just go and be able to
play with 3d printers and and see what
you could do with some of these these
awesome things like like um you know the
University of Arkansas folks using three
who would have thought you'd use 3d
printer to make clothing yeah correct
you know just things like I don't want
to wear those like plastics and stuff
like that I want to wear what the 3d per
ticket printer I want to wear soft
fabric yeah exactly but but what they're
doing those they're using it for
embellishments and things so this is the
creative embellishment process but it's
just the process to see what you can do
with it we're can it go what does it
need to go you know the tangle art
bracelets have you heard of those um one
more time to take a go art hey go art T
AG o AR C so that's a bracelet that you
you can and the business model on this
is beautiful it's black and right now
with display but you can hold a pattern
through ble up to it and will change the
bracelets pattern to match the pattern
so think about that the visible is this
I saw the bracelets 200 bucks 250 right
but the pattern is a dollar pattern
Hoarders come on how many paid you're
gonna have at a dollar it's affordable
you can make your own so some of these
things you can virtualize into business
models even Djoser only three years ago
or so we were messing around with uh i
think it was called the moto at moto x
watch and yeah we were messing around a
place is it the one that you can you can
sort of follows your your movements
around we were this I don't know no
there's one like that a couple couple
years ago we were messing around the
designs on it and matching it to
clothing that we were wearing yeah
different wash designs for the arms yes
that would be that was like
fashion design but actually you know
there's a reason why like out of all
these different things that we could
invent into the world though you know
we're doing what we're doing right now I
like to think of it as there is a reason
why I'm rather than maybe like a
nihilistic perspective of there is no
reason why and and like the reason might
be just because it's fun yeah yeah I can
do it
yeah and in in in this case it's like
the things that I've led you to who you
are and where you are today the reason
why you might not have pursued any of
those other things that were very
creatively enticing for you to decide to
do was because your soul was maybe meant
for the divinity of the current state
that you're in bringing forth what you
are building today into the world and
that is exactly what the world needs and
maybe with that type of a perspective it
might be a little bit more a little less
anxious little less depressing a little
bit more divine at times so I want to
also mention since we're on this topic
just a little bit longer on the hunt
patents we're teaching about prior art
this is something that I think that many
people don't know is that they're cost a
lot of money to file a patent but it
costs almost nothing for you to design
something and publish a paper about it
you're so internet and you'd actually
have to you have to design to the point
that you can show how it works you don't
have to build it but you do need to get
it to a point where you show that it's
functional and it can work so you can
you can take something and put it out
there and in the prior art by publishing
it somewhere a magazine or your own blog
yep you know you stablish the ownership
that that kind of way and and it's
really an interesting way to protect a
design but not have to spend the money
to put out a patent if that's what you
you know you still want to do yeah it's
it's just you know you know not
everything has to be patented there
there's some good some things out there
that that should this be out there for
the good of humanity yeah you know and
nobody owns it yeah yeah and you know if
you've got some of those ideas you know
that's what you do but I really want to
be that one person who created that
your kids in the backseat and they've
got that blowup divider where they can't
touch each other they make it they can't
see each other I want to be whoever it
is who did that what because I was like
that was brilliant
wait we absolutely bring wait question
for those of us that are ignorant of
what at the interpersonal children child
is Oh interactions are in the backseat
why is it Margaret
you don't remember when you were young
you would sit next to your brother or
sister in a seat and poke at them and
they'd sit and then like mommy's
touching me mommy's touching me mommy so
Jane a he's making faces at me he's
making faces at me you know but you
would be in the middle of drive you
would be driving and all you hear is
that noise from the backseat now you've
got this divider and they can't see it
like it is your own little cocoon world
oh my goodness crazy think this is just
a it's a blow you can blow it up and
yeah that is so interesting people come
up to solve problems are pretty funny
sometimes Alfredo and I do that too we
poke each other and we're like oh we
have to put a blow-up divider here
imagine that in tech offices like the
blow-up dividers I'm being annoying
cubicle cubicle said they're so just
like that one can get involved in the
patenting process by just having some
prior art to prevent others from having
yeah and then there's that and then
there is the process of pounding there's
created there's creating something open
source or the world as well yeah so
there's all these different types of
ways and I just love the spirit that you
have about invention we have that same
spirit about invention and it just it
really it's crazy how much easier it
becomes to want to to to invent when you
have time when you have because you have
food and you have water you have
sheltering AC electricity you've got
your basic necessities and at that point
you're you're good to go when I was
younger I never probably
because of the things I had to do around
your house to keep the house going
exactly you know keep the bills paid
keep the bills paid and those kinds of
things but now that you you've got it in
your steady you know your brain sort of
switches on to other things and
depending how you're wired might explain
how your brain switches because I always
always wired and taught you help you
have you give yeah so I just look at
things like well how can we make that
better what what am I seeing you know I
have like friends that like one one
colleague her mom wasn't eating and she
had to call her cousins to tell her to
you know and she didn't know that since
the doctor called her you know her mom
was very sick at that point and so she's
gonna had to call her cousins who lived
there and she had to fly down there
stuff and she said we're honor what we
do and I said well we could
unobtrusively IOT enabled house mm-hmm
we can put sensors to know when the
refrigerator doors are being open and
when the pantry doors are being opened
which are indicative of she's eating hmm
dishes have to be done and things like
that these are all indicators that you
know not solid ones but they're
indicators of habits and so I love I
love when people say what can we do to
help with this we built a solar skull
you know and we're gonna it's it's it's
it's a school in a box actually is what
it is with solar panels so think of what
this could be used for in Costa Rica or
these places where there's natural
disasters yeah it's less than $200 for
the components including the solar panel
to run the electricity all the lessons
are on a hard drive and in here and we
can get these really robust terminals
off of Amazon that that had these
antennas that can make their own land
and children could continue in these
areas where there's natural disasters to
have schooling school in a box it's
solar school we call it the solar school
and then because it uses solar power so
you don't have to have electricity so
there's no infrastructure required it's
what you need some Sun yeah yeah okay
you have some Sun yeah and then the hard
drives connected there's a display as
well well it's there but then we give
them these terminals and they connect
and they make their own little land well
they make their own little a yeah the
lessons are on a hard drive yep on
in the solar skull which is you know
friend electricity so the song run
electricity this is we use uh know that
we've had some interest with some groups
wanting to use it for Bible studies and
things like that and disaster relief
yes aster relief it's it's less than two
hundred dollars for the components and
these are you could probably get it even
cheaper these are things we buy
off-the-shelf yeah yeah you know and
these are things that Janani I can't say
ever say her last name I always screw it
up but she was like what can we do to
help areas in India she's from India to
get you know education and these kinds
of things really we could probably do a
school apostasy we're gonna fry but
these require you to have some basic you
know electricity knowledge you know
resistors and components you know how do
you use solar panels just some basic
knowledge but with these basic knowledge
you can do so much good for people what
these solar schools and these kinds of
things it's it's just awesome
what you can do yeah there was I think a
cons of relief in Africa he also sent
solar panels to be able to a very small
solar panels to be able to charge I
don't think yes though like that and I
thought that what you were describing
solar schools so interesting as well
just how can you solve for more ubiquity
and education across the world without
the necessity of the infrastructure in
those locations because if you don't
have it what are you gonna do so now you
have to figure out and we don't want you
to have to put up this huge
infrastructure had to do so what can we
put in a box so at the stem telecast
that I did we had two young ladies there
from Australia one of them was the the
is EF winner last year and they were
actually and her thing is everything old
is new again so they have taken a
flat-pack a water purifying system so
water purifying system that they did and
it's on the flat pack can be can be
towed very you know very economical very
flat pack not use once they have right
now it just so huge and they debuted
that the IeSF a couple weeks ago and you
know
is her it's just Mackenzie is so amazed
I can't say enough about Mackenzie she's
just so amazing for a seventeen-year-old
who looks at things differently so last
year she won for the contralateral
breast shield which I had to look up
with all those words meant you know but
if you remember back in the old days
they used to use sort of like a fish
scale kind of approach to create armor
for the horses you know back in the
dynasty whatever right she what she did
was she used copper which is a more a
conductive metal of rejecting the the
radiation and she used took and she took
all these little pieces of copper and
hooked them together like chainmail and
made it so it could drape across the
breast that's not getting the radiation
treatment making it much more effective
during radiation treatments of
protecting that breast this is a 16 year
old for god sakes
those little x-ray skirts yeah right but
they're not made of lead which is bad
for you it's made of copper which is
fine you know and it's it's more
protective so it's not harmful and it's
more protective and this is a 16 year
old but her thought is everything old is
new again so she looked at those yeah
she looked at these these things that
they did for it for to protect the
horses and came up with this idea the
same way with the water purification
system with her and I cannot provide for
me remember the other young lady's name
but worked together and came up with
this water purification system I can
give you a picture and everything of it
then I did an interview of it on our
stem telecast but it was I mean there's
such amazing young people out there
there's solving some of these things and
I would have never thought to go back in
history to pick up something to do
something different to be honest with
you but now she's made me think you know
what else is like that exactly what else
is like that yeah there's a lot that we
can learn from how civilization got to
where it is kitchens is all these so
many things are gone now from from the
civilizations of the past that were
actually in many ways more Intel
we have today right let's take some of
those things and implement them today so
okay we've sent a lot of time on patents
sorry that's right yeah but I love it
and inventions patents inventions kids
inventing like all that is phenomenally
important that's why we spent so much
time on it but now uh-huh let's
transition to data security and privacy
so you are teaching me about this
there's encryption there's obfuscation
yeah and there's depth of defense yeah
there are these okay let's go let's
unpack these encryption first let's talk
about that for a bit okay well there's
all kinds of different types of
encryption the bigger the key is the
harder it is to break but encryption
isn't how many how many characters yeah
or things I say that 200 how many how
many you know so if you're doing a es
256 encryption okay which is a standard
right and and I had somebody say I lost
my key and I need to get it back how
long will it take was probably 10 times
10 to the 52nd power if you were to go
to all the iterations to try to find
that key now you might get lucky and
find in the first five years of your
life but 10 times 10 to the 50 second is
a whole lot of time and you know a
single computer is not going to do it so
the bigger that number 256 128 is after
it the harder it is to do that are we
doing like more than 256 right now I
don't think I've seen anything beyond
that that that can reasonably be done
and is that taking like your file let's
say it's a just classic PDF file you
don't want anyone to see it right so
then you're taking the ones and zeros
and you're you're changing the number so
just just think of it as oh gosh I'm
trying to think there's some really good
movies out there but the very first Tom
Hanks one Angels & Demons yeah I think
you know it's talking about right and
they talk about encryption it's you're
changing it in such a way that only you
know how to undo it
that's encryption so you're not doing a
simple substitution but you're just
changing in such a way that you're the
only one who knows how to put it back -
right so you can read it and you have to
have the key to do that
without this key you can't put it back -
right so that's that's encryption in its
simplest form and you probably don't
want to write that on like so many
papers or laying around yeah that's
that's usually not according story corny
stir your crypto key yeah well where do
you then like what is a good place Oh
key storage places that you can start I
don't they see it too though um you know
there's some trust factors that have to
go into some of these things you do have
there does come a time like you have to
trust something cuz I does IBM tell its
clients that they'll take care of them
if we're doing if we're running their
systems for them a lot of times we will
have the key mm-hmm where that data and
sometimes what's how the client we would
feel more console they kept the key
mm-hmm
it just depends to be honest with you so
there's that um
then there's obvious keishon is this you
make it look like something else you try
to hide it you just try to hide it you
know so social security patterns because
when people try to look like for Social
Security you know you're you're
technically looking for the pattern you
know three numbers - two numbers - four
numbers so you know take it out jumble
it around you don't make it look so
obvious if that's what it is and in you
know security through office Gatien as
we say it's not the brightest thing to
do but some people still believe this
works it can it can work and in some
cases if you
oh I remember simple things for for
testing the fences if there's a weak
slow flow we'll get we'll get there
we'll get there but it's yeah okay and
then and then but I think everybody has
agreed that the the most common is what
we call depth and defense so think of a
castle so you got the castle this is
your enterprise and you've built these
concentric moats around them of
different times some of them might have
oil and fire and some of them might be
water and some of these might be
crocodiles or snakes or whatever okay
and they're dis concentric circles and
for a bad person to break in they have
to cross all those concentric circles
the more circles you have their heart of
the circles are that's called depth and
defense so that's the easiest way to
explain it I could go into you know host
intrusion detection and stuff like that
and then people's eyes glaze over and
they
get lost so it's easier to explain it
with the castle mode that's really
reliable
kind of mentality kind of things you get
a notification when they start attacking
the first moat you should get a
notification if you've done it properly
you get a notification when they're
trying to cross the first month even the
moats way way out there you got people
watching yeah hey you got to watch us
out there watching it kind of thing so
you with your security operation center
and so there's those kinds of Defense's
that we talk about you know we like to
have encryption because if if for some
reason so I meet does get all the way
through you're just making it harder for
them to get the data and get at the data
so we like to encrypt it yep you know
and we can't depend any more on all
these depth and defense decryptions now
as we move to the cloud either mmm
because you know that relies on somebody
because some people sometimes people
forgotten all this stuff exists and when
they move to the cloud they forget that
they have to re-enable all that stuff
because they haven't been doing it it's
an enterprise people on high you know
some some group over here has been doing
it for them and they forget that it
existed and so when they go to the cloud
sometimes they forget they need to do
all these things still again to protect
it so you know so you try to make it
harder for them to do that kind of stuff
and then you try to remind folks your
application must defend itself also so
and that's an old concept that's
becoming new again actually so when I
went to university that was one of the
things they taught you you defend
yourself you do not depend on anything
else so that would be like you'd be a
very rich person and not being you know
shown to have any hand-to-hand combat
moves or anything like that you know I
just look cute and walk around and if
someone attacks me from Tulsa definitely
so so now you want to teach this thing
to defend itself you want to teach us
some hand-to-hand combat you want to
teach it to reject things that look
strange and silly and things like that
so the application must now defend
itself too so you want to make sure they
can't get through the concentric modes
if they do get through the concentric
modes you want to make sure they can't
get at the data because you're moving it
around it's encrypted so somebody can
snoop around they can't see it they're
going what this looks like garbage let
me look at the drive that looks like
garbage now let me see if I can get in
the application
well the applications spend in the
office if you do all that that's really
good security dad sure you privacy there
right that sounds like world-class
security it is world-class security if
you do all those things like my security
colleagues are probably now cringing
horribly why it's very late it's the
simplest way to say I want to make the
simplest way I know very technical
people can have their place for other
very technical people that want to learn
but for the ones that want to research
yes yes let's get the surface level out
there to people and then slowly we can
talk about the more technical stuff well
so ok now this process that you just
described it is available to IBM clients
it's available diving points but this is
a normal coding set of methods and then
generally accepted practice for
everybody to do these kinds of so like
not just clients like Hirsch of a group
like they probably do you know most of
the coders should do similar security
most enterprises should use similar
security practices to be honest with you
you know if you're if you're a good
world-class protector of the data you're
doing these kinds of practices you're
penetration testing your applications
that make sure they're secure your
penetration testing the the concentric
circles your your defenses to make sure
that they're in place and making sure
that they're doing what they're supposed
to be doing for you and protecting your
client and your clients data so after
you have set up the co centric circles
and all this infrastructure then you
attack yourself to see if it's working
say you get the notification and then
that's the strength testing yeah which
let's unpack this way you get this so
you get these things these guys are
called white hackers why hackers white
hat does that mean like they're good
guys good good good good guys they they
have some that they have several the
same techniques they're trained the same
way hackers are they watch the dark web
and they learn from these guys but
they're gonna try all their tips and
techniques to
see if they can break in so it's sort of
like like some of these museums hire
people to come and see if they can
burglar into the museum Oh interest I
said we're going to the museum they're
trying to burglar into your assistance
to see if they can what they can still
and what they can find and it's really
cool these techniques that these guys do
a lot of different things so like with
my stuff I get people a little upset
because I'll say I want you to break it
and they'll go what I said break it I
want you to really throw the book at it
and give it a go this is the only way
I'm going to know have we done
everything we can to protect ourselves
you know I don't want you to look at
policy and what we're supposed to be
doing and I want you to give it the best
shot you can you try to break into it
why hackers so I don't think yes white
hat hackers yes white hat hackers yellow
hackers and then there is also the
people that get hired to attempt to
burglarize museums it's so interesting
the same kind of people that's because
you're good guys that are testing it to
make sure that the bad guys can get it
very interesting and then this was also
interesting and we kind of thought we
kind of talked about this a little bit
but the the low-and-slow
we've started talking about that a bit
earlier yeah yeah so a lot of times so
the best way to think of the way hackers
think is like I told Jurassic Park okay
the first movie or the last Sarah I love
dress apart for the last two Raptors are
there and I know you don't see them but
you hear these noises they're making and
they ask you know what's going on and
the responses they're systematically
testing the fence for weaknesses and
that's what hackers do they try to
systematically test your moats to find
out you know has this ground filled in
and can I skate across here or something
like that and so hackers try to do that
another technique they try to do is what
I call the low and slow where they know
that there's certain levels something's
going to happen they just don't know
what that level is so they'll start very
low and see if they can trip it so they
might say you know like well let me let
me try this or like a baby let me try
and pull this little piece off here and
see think notices me I've just taken it
and I'll wait look around see if
anybody's paying attention to me and
notice
attention so I've got a piece of cake no
one sees it right we'd grab a bigger
piece of cake if anybody notices your
earlier in the night right right so
they'll do it repeatedly until they trip
something once they trip something to go
okay
now I know about where that level is on
this thing let me just see what the next
level is so they're trying to see where
the responses will come in and and they
can combine several of those things
together to try to break into the system
if you're not careful so you got a guard
against low and slows off so not just
you know a direct frontal attack
you know the Huns are coming at you
think of the think of the what's that
horse that they had that they hit in the
Trojan horse yeah I think of a Trojan
horse like that yeah so they're trying
to hide and figure out how they can
slide it underneath your wires they're
so many different ways to tap in test
testing the fences taking just a little
bit at a time the infrastructure that
needs to be built out to prevent that
the why and the people that pay
attention to it and the knowledge that
they get from there their threat
intelligent systems and bringing that
all together you know so and this is
where augmented intelligence I know it's
that this week they've been talking AI
and sometimes it's artificial
intelligent and augment and I think it's
more augmented to be honest with you but
that's where these argument and
intelligent things come in that they can
do these things so so like it learns
your habit so wouldn't it be cool if
they know you you're a soccer analyst
security operation analyst and they know
that these are like ten things you
always do the tickets being assigned to
you to go work let me go do these ten
things so you don't have to go do it
here let me give you the data and now
you can start do whatever your next
steps are but that not be cool they
didn't know it learns what your habits
are and helps you by doing these things
for you in advance so we can speed up
the process a little bit you know so
when I think of things that are that are
coming those are kinds of things I think
are really cool with security being able
to it to learn these kinds of things for
it to be able to take all of the
gobbledygook that we say in security and
it and sometimes it is Russian or is
when my boss says you're speaking PhD
level can you come down
you know be able to take that and say
putting into the language of a sigh so
that they can understand that they
understand the business impact of what's
happening it's one thing to say hey this
network segments being attacked or this
servers been owned or something like
that and the sites they'll go yeah what
does that mean to me what's that in
English yeah you say your banking
application is now offline and nobody
can submit checks yeah that's what the
side so wants to know at that point they
don't want he doesn't want to know all
this he wants know what the bottom line
business impact is to him yeah so he can
then go deal with it and whatever your
whether it's social media or whatever
triage has to do at that point yeah
making the complex relatable to the
point where people can take action with
it right away correct and then you can
also talk about the technicalities later
about how to prevent that in the future
so what about the other applications of
IBM's data security technology to
clients is this is this a kind of a this
isn't a one package fits all it's all
this it's a it's tailored to every
client personally and does then the
client get to pick which parts of IBM
State security they can take and apply
to their business or is it individually
architected for each person how does
that well the security business has
offerings that that are given so there's
data loss prevention so so if you
worried about data leaving you select
you want to have some data loss
prevention okay we can do anything from
monitoring so we can set up a security
operation center and use the one that
IBM has we can help you set up your own
security operations center if you want
so there's services so there's as a
service that you can buy out right or we
can help you set up those services and
set up the software and you can do it
yourself so there's a whole spectrum of
things that you can select to do
depending upon what best suits you or
the client you know and what what
outcome they're trying
to achieve so you nose and it might be a
combination of things that they run
themselves and so as the services that
they buy you know because it you know as
an as a service we see a broad spectrum
across a bunch of clients and so
sometimes you want to see something here
that's applicable over there
where if you're running it yourself you
won't see those kinds of indicators but
again it's what the outcome the client
is trying to achieve that we we try to
do solution for okay this has been
insightful what do you think about the
future of like quantum computing and
quantum encryption does this seem do you
guys talk about this a lot we do we do
and and it's very much like when when
Watson was first coming along so some of
the use cases I had with Watson was
wouldn't it be awesome of Watson's could
watch the dark web and predict when
something was going to happen before it
happened and we could get defenses in
place before it happened mhm mhm yeah
that to me is like the ultimate thing so
we look at quantum computing and quantum
encryption
it's just encryption on steroids right
like the unbreakable so if you look at
AES 256 and how long it takes to break
that just think of what it would take
with quantum encryption to break that
and I will never say that it's the
unbreakable encryption but it's gonna be
pretty darn close I believe to being
unbreakable and it's going to provide
that that safety but that alone is not
going to do it has to be coupled with
other things to enable what yeah
blockchain and potentially other pieces
of technology to really make it strong
and make it useful for human beings
because having an unbreakable piece of
encryption without something else around
is not going to be as much fun you know
so we have to figure out how to best use
it and leverage it what do you think
about exponential technology
exacerbating wealth inequality help me
with that one like although the argument
that everybody that's in the lowest
socioeconomic status
slowly coming up is very true that
people at the very top are going much
faster oh yeah they're accelerating yes
so what should we do about that that one
that one's a hard one to me and you
almost you know what one party you says
oh then Texas we have the Robin Hood
laws for the schools this is the
wealthier school districts have to send
part of their money down to the not
wealthier school districts and you know
my children were in school you're
thinking why am i paying double for this
I've paid my taxes now they want to
march in the van I have to give them
more money because the money's been sent
out out of thing in the but then you
have to stop and think the only way that
these people are going to come up as
long as they're willing to to put forth
that effort right you know we can't
distinct you can have that Robin Hood I
don't know how many states have that
Robin took a whole state of Texas does
minor Steen is yes it's the whole state
in the instant per County the wealthier
school yeah well your school districts
the way through school districts give
part of their money to help subsidize
the the other ones that are not so right
and you look at it and sometimes you
just you get frustrated with it but
didn't you look at you step back and go
it's the right thing to do because if
not these non these these these places
wouldn't be able to afford to do some of
the things and they might need their
free reduced lunches they might need
their science textbooks exactly exactly
and they would want the tools to if you
were in there exactly and I was in their
shoes
okay I I we had no money so you know we
were we were very dependent upon you
know other places you know for me to get
things you know I had to go to public
library things like that I couldn't own
anything because the money we had went
elsewhere kind of thanks so you know you
would want to you guys step back and
look at it you know as long as they're
willing to pull the you know oh wait
they're willing I'm fine with with
helping them to raise them up to be
honest with you I'd rather do that and I
know those who have way up here would
really rather keep what they got I get
it but you know you have to look back
and step back and look like that the
Bill and Melinda
Melissa gates foundations and things
like that and the things that they give
back to the communities I I like to look
at you know how can I find grants or
apply for words that come with money and
say I would love to win this award take
that money and make IOT kits and give
them to some place that could actually
use them and in you never know what the
next Albert Einstein is going to be it
could be in these other districts so
you've got to enable them to be able to
realize it totally giving people
opportunity you gotta give them an
opportunity I was / tunity to actualize
exactly it fullest exactly and you know
I understand the people that are up here
and we're not up there milk my family's
not up there but you know we you know
again we're taught you know you share
what you have and we share you share
what you have sure what you have yeah
should I be happy if you're miserable
exactly yeah
how about we ask you a couple of these I
could work more rapid-fire questions at
the end what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world this
sounded my husband's laughter mm-hmm and
my children's laughter just because it
indicates to me they're happy yes yes
they're happy and content so like I'd
like the feeling of uncontrollable
laughter just it is you never you rarely
get to feel it and when you do feel it
it's only five or maybe ten seconds at
most straight uh-huh and and it's hard
it's kind of like deja of whoo except
it's a little longer than deja vu but
I'd love to go back to those moments and
just feel what it feels yeah unfettered
feelings that just of happiness when
you're you're laughing yes yes yes how
about do you think we're alone in the
cosmos no and you know expand a little
bit I think there are other beings out
there to be honest with you I probably
know I'm fired from IBM there to me
they're there there are it's so vast
there's no way you can absolutely say
there is not another sign of life out
there it's just too vast the
probabilities are not in our favor
with that one making that statement and
I've learned you never make absolutes
statements yeah yeah yeah some binary
statements help though like it does it
does and like this those are those are
no more knowns so they're knowns yeah
yeah that one that one the probability
is is if you make a statement that we
are alone the probabilities you're going
to be wrong it's too fast
play the odds yeah and then do you think
we're in a simulation I hope not I would
hate to wake up and find out when ready
player one wouldn't you not that that
would be bad right but you know I would
I would hate to be like ready player one
so and I'm sure you're familiar with
that that movie but Ernest Cline but
yeah yeah and the book was awesome too
by the way the book was to me more
awesome the movie but I would hate to
wake up or the matrix that this is the
life were living I would hope that this
is very real because it's been a good
run yeah it is it's a it is a good run
humanity's had a good run and I mean
look at ever all the problems that was
solved you know
Parkinson's would be the next big when
I'd love to solve my mother has it you
know and heart disease would be the next
two big ones and you know everything
when you picked those things cuz they're
personal right so those would be the
next things I'd love to see solved yeah
I want to keep seeing humanity run but
at the same time I I do think that the
reason why we asked the question so much
is because proud I like the idea that
you said of the waking up and you're not
even in the world that you were in
anymore and it's something else like
ready player one we asked question a lot
because we like to expand people's minds
to the awareness of the potential of
what simulation theory is actually like
yeah so this has been very insightful
this has been really really insightful
thank you well thank you for having time
I've actually had a good time thank you
good Aaronic glad to hear that we've
learned a lot about encryption
navigation depth and defense testing
those fences that the slow method of
creeping in and taking some cake along
the way so yes you can get away with the
castle and moat analogy concentric
circles is really good and even patents
and knowing how to the invention mindset
the inventor mindset and getting out and
and making even some prior art if that's
uh if that's if that's what we can do
for the world bring some open source
stuff as well so this has been very
insightful and let's see if we can we'll
put some links to in the bio to get your
work on your site and then we will we'll
also tell the viewers at home thanks for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it if
you had a good time make sure to share
the content with other people make sure
to go and create with the content don't
just consume go and make something with
it go and talk about these things on
video or in writing I'm going build
something with it yourself join the
family subscribe comment below with your
thoughts we'd love to share them as well
also join us on patreon so we can keep
doing cool things like bringing the
equipment to awesome conferences and
highlighting brilliant leaders so thank
you everyone for tuning in and we'll see
you soon
you